there's a kind of feeling
for the ambition of this
interdisciplinary work that often is
very happy it's like look I there's all
this these disciplines and these
different people doing research if they
talk to each other and they interact
they can it can things can go really
great you get this cross-pollination you
can get these insights and that's true
I'm not denying that but um
um can toads and rabbits were introduced
into Australia to pretty disastrous
results too um sometimes you take
something works perfectly well where it
is and you try and use it somewhere else
um inconsiderately and you get you get
bad results so I'm going to talk about a
case where I think people have been
getting bad results um hopefully they'll
stop doing it but also as a general
cautionary tale um now sitting at the
center of this talk is going to be some
claims about Bell's theorem and the
violation of Bell's theorem in an Ideal
World I could explain that for people
who don't understand um if you don't
know anything about it um Tim nen
actually I did an interview with him
recently it's two and a half hours long
and it'll go through in all detail you
want what that's all about I'll just cut
it to the chase at a certain point and
tell you what Belle proved um and what
the experiments proved and if you don't
believe me it it'll take longer to get
okay
so philosophers and scientists often try
to represent causal structure in various
idealized and simplified ways and I want
to talk about ah sorry yeah I got to
stay here this is going to kill me um in
in various idealized ways and and the
you know they're gross simplifications
and less gross simplifications I just
want to talk about two ways that
philosophers have used to represent and
scientists have have used to represent
causal structure this first one are
examples of what are called neuron
diagrams uh there's a nice book by Ned
Hall and and and Lori Paul on causation
that use a lot of these diagrams and
again it's extremely idealized very
simplified binary kind of system the
circles represent events and the the
edges the neurons uh are either exitor
or excitatory or
inhibitory um the ones with the arrows
excite so the ideas is and time goes up
on this so you have events at the bottom
and then that can excite a later event
and the little circles are inhibitory so
that'll prevent that from happening and
then you can kind of read it upwards and
then given such a diagram given the the
inputs at the bottom you sort of figure
out given that's the structure what's
going to happen now these two diagrams
are for an example that that that Ned
has used a long a long time that has um
these two kids Billy and Susie who are
just vandals and they're throwing rocks
at windows and um they're both aiming at
the same window and this is a example of
in what's called in the literature late
prevention we can imagine they throw at
the same time but Billy's a little
faster his rock is just ahead of su's um
his rock hits the window shatters it her
Rock sails right through the broken
window even if he hadn't thrown the
problem is you might saywell how do I
know that Billy you say Billy Billy you
broke that window right um but Billy can
say look if I hadn't if I hadn't thrown
this window still would have broken
right because her Rock would have broken
it so it's kind of causal over
determination late prevention case um so
don't blame me right if you use a very
simple counterfactual analysis uh and so
the the the these two structures are OB
obviously different they give you
different causal paths the one on the
left is if Billy throws early and the
one on the right is if suie is slightly
early okay um and you'll notice up there
the the the only difference there
symmetric except at the very end where
I've put that little inhibitory thing
that is if billies goes through then not
only does he break the window but he he
inhibits or prevents sues from breaking
the window right because it's already
broken and it's the other way around if
she now the red circles are supposed to
be things you might be able to control
so you the big question is if you have
this very idealized picture of the
underlying causal structure okay how can
I figure out what the underlying
structure is because there's certain
things I can do or I can observe right I
can e some some things I can control
some things I can observe some things
are latent or hidden and this is what
I'm trying to get at I can observe the
result I can see whether the window
broke or not and I'm imagining you can
have these two interventions you can or
you may or may not stay Billy's hand
right prevent him from throwing or
prevent her from throwing and then if
you if you excite those things you'll
see what happens right what's clear is
that if you stay Billy's hand in this
diagram if you don't his he's going to
break the the chain will be this causes
Billy's throw causes the window to break
and prevents her hers from breaking it
if you stay his hand then those neurons
won't fire hers will go straight through
the window will break she'll be
responsible and then you just reverse
the roles of Billy and
Susie if she's throwing a little faster
okay so I hope everybody sees how to
read these things um now you can ask all
right let's suppose we have constraints
on what we can see we can see actually
whether Billy or Susie or both throw
their rocks we can see whether the
window breaks but we can't see the fine
details of the intervening process okay
um and and then what you that one back
sorry then what you notice is that
um what from what we can observe we
can't figure out which of those two
diagrams if either is correct because
they give rise to the to the same
surface appearance right what we'll find
is that if we if we stay neither of
their hands the window breaks if we stay
one or the other their hands the window
breaks and if we stay both of their
hands the window doesn't break but
that's in common between those two
graphs so you have two different
underlying causal structures that are
giving rise to the same um empirical
observations and therefore you now have
an epistemic problem right you say I
can't really be sure what the underlying
causal structure is here
good um now let's suppose we can do
something else now I want to suggest
this isn't in the literature I just want
to suggest something else which isn't
usually talked about suppose there's a
different action
suppose I I can't stay Bobby's or
Susie's hand but I can delay it right
just slow them down a little bit what
effect can that have
well suppose if I don't delay it they
throw Billy's a little faster his Rock
will hit so we're on this side but if I
delay his hand enough so now Susie's
rock is a little faster what I will have
done is changed you from this causal
structure to that causal structure so
that's that's a kind of beta causation
if you will right is a an effect on the
very causal structure but because I'm
switching between two causal structures
that are on the surface identical I also
can't tell that I can't tell whether my
staying Billy's hand had any effect at
all right because in in fact on the
causal structure because in fact if he
had thrown first it did but if he thrown
second it didn't matter that I delayed
him right it's going to be the same
either way so I can't figure out the
counterfactual dependency I can't see
the counterfactual dependencies there
good um and so this is the last so and
in this case whether or not the delay
has any effect at all cannot be gleaned
from the observable data um if you give
me the actual underlying structure of
course I know if I know all the details
I can tell you whether whether delay
made a difference or not but I can't
tell it
observationally so what's the moral
um the reason that the delay will have
no observable consequences is because
the two different causal structures
themselves have all the same observable
consequences then hence the effect of
the delay indeed whether it had any
effect at all cannot be determined by
observation and it's also obvious that
someone who can see uh only see whether
or not the window breaks cannot possibly
tell whether a delay was put in on
either Bobby or suie right so again you
have this other thing which is because
whether or not I put in this delay has
no observable consequences
Downstream I can't use it for signaling
right if I can if I'm trying to to send
somebody a signal and that person all
they can see is the window right and all
I can do is either delay Bobby or not
delay Bobby I can't use my ability to do
that I I am I may be doing something I
may be actually switching the causal
structure but I can't signal with it
okay this is very simple case where that
happens um so that's that we would say
in this setup I would call this a no
signaling result right given the causal
structure this intervention can't be
used to send signals it can actually it
may actually have a causal influence it
may change the causal
situation now the other thing I mean
these neuron diagrams are very very
simple you use them for evaluating
counterfactuals and you use them for
probing certain counterfactual analysis
of causation a more serious thing that
scientists use are of course causal
graphs um they're much more subtle
because they're not just binary the the
the neuron diagrams either the neuron
fires or it doesn't it's just very
simple kind of thing
um but now we again have these nodes
we're going to put down a directed graph
we're going to have nodes the nodes are
connected to other nodes and one node
firing can have either an e excitatory
or inhibitory effect on whether the
probability of another node
firing um
and in the neuron diagrams you know
there's no probabilities it's all ones
or zeros but but in a linear causal
model and again you're now going to be
using these um sorry you're going to be
using these similar looking directed
graphs but they're different because in
a linear causal mod model the edges
indicate a kind of causal influence and
that can have different strengths right
so you also have to put these numbers on
the edges that tell you how strongly
will the effect will the likelihood of
the effect go up or go down depending
upon how strongly this thing is is
firing and the simplest case
mathematically of course is for that to
be a linear relation that again is
obviously a vast oversimplification in
the real world all these things
nonlinear but you know for small
variations you can always approximate
something pretty well
linearly
um so we have this you know a linear
causal graph is again self-consciously a
great idealization but you can calculate
the stuff so it's nice
now you have the same problem and this
has been the subject of a lot of
research and really active research I
was around when Clark gmmore was doing
doing this stuff starting this stuff
back in the 1980s about the same time
Judea Pearl was looking at these things
you set up these graphs and then you can
notice again there are certain things
you can control or observe and other
latent nodes you can't and more
importantly the actual underlying
structure is latent you can't see the
underlying structure so what you're
trying to do is see what you can see and
then infer what you can infer about the
underlying structure from the actual
data but you what you immediately see is
is just as in the Suzie case there are
going to be lots of these graphs where
they'll give rise to the same observable
Behavior even though they have a
different underlying structure and the
other thing you see immediately if you
if you do the combinatorics is that as
soon as you get a lot of these nodes the
combinatorics kills you I mean the
number of different directed graphs you
can you can write down you know goes
very high me what Gore was working on at
the time was search right how do I cut
cut down the search space of graphs I
look at because I can't look at all of
them it's just not
practical um a usual you know the usual
constraint in this case you're using
directed acylic graphs because you think
of these edges as causation and you
think causes have to precede their
effects so the causes can't go around in
circles right so that automatically Cuts
you down to to the AY graphs but still
there are way too many of them easy to
calculate how many um
so here you have to assign these weights
now another funny thing happens here
which is because you're assigning these
weights what you expect to happen is
going to depend on the exact weights you
put
down and so and and another thing is
from a a certain node you can have
multiple of these edges that represent
different causal influences right or you
can have an edge that goes from here to
this one and another other Edge that
goes from this to this to that and some
of them can be exory and some of them
can be inhibitory right when we give
people
vaccines there's one Edge that's
inhibitory from you're getting the
illness but unfortunately another Edge
if it's say A you know a a killed live
vaccine some some number of people
actually get the illness right so
there's some chance you'll be worse off
if you take it there's some chance
you'll be better off if you take it it
really depends a lot on the weights of
those nodes to figure out whether you
should take the vaccine
right but then once you see that you say
well for very very very special values
of these weights I can actually cancel
out an exory and
inhibitory effect so it's zero net
effect right I'm giving people all these
vaccines and I see no difference at all
in their sickness rates and one thing
you say look vaccine's not doing
anything but it could be no no no it's
actually it's actually creating
more sickness in this group and
preventing sickness in that group and in
fact different people would have gotten
sick but the statistics would be the
same because these effects just cancel
each other out now one of the things
that happens in this literature is then
people say well
um all right this is where okay so the I
already said that you needed to
constrain these graphs one thing you do
is by temporal order that means you
don't allow ret proc causation or causal
Cycles now here's where I am
so there's the vacine example I've
already said this stuff you can set
weights so that the net effect will be
statistically zero even though it's
actually having causal effects and so
what people do is they say look um we've
got all these we've got all of these
graphs we're trying to cut down the
number of of possible causal structures
were considering just don't take them
seriously if they're fine-tuned in that
way right so there's this principle
called faithfulness or no fine-tuning
that basically says if you've set up a
graph and you've put these weights on it
such that a manipulation you can do here
has causal causal connection to
something observable here but you don't
see any statistical changes because of
everything's canceling out just ignore
that that's fine-tuning that's possible
but very implausible don't believe it
it's like fine I mean it's the same
fine-tuning people we've talked about in
cosmology how fine-tuned is the initial
State how bad is fine-tuning that's all
perfectly fine um
and what you'd like to do and this is
what Gore was doing and pearl was doing
was just say okay what good principles
do I have that will take me from The
observed data to plausible underlying
causal structures constrained in part by
the data constrained by other
theoretical considerations sometimes but
you know you see the problem you just
have this overgeneration of
possibilities um and again the more
latent nodes and in a lot of cases most
of these nodes are latent I mean this
was about you know like with the monkeys
how you know what data can we get right
I've got all of this incredible causal
structure but I can only get my hands on
the poop okay you know well what can I
do with that right so
um
anyway so that was a piece of
methodological advice that comes in a
reasonable way out of the linear causal
graph program that says if you've got a
theory that's fine tuned
bad but then you say well how what's the
indication that the theory is fine-tuned
and now what they use notice if I
fine-tune the theory so that changing
this variable here has no ST statistical
difference there I also get a no
signaling theorem right I can't send a
message from here to Here by twiddling
this knob because you've set things up
so no matter how to knobs the the
observable statistics anyway will be the
same at the other end so then they say
oh here's so here's the piece of advice
if there's no signaling between this and
this there should be no causal
connections right reject a theory that
has causal connections between two nodes
if the if you can't see if you can
manipulate one and you can see the other
and these man culations don't make any
statistical difference right so that's
the methodological moral that comes out
of that
tradition um you say yeah of course
logically it's possible that you've got
a causal connection there logically it's
possible but if you can't signal your
best advice is to throw that graph away
right throw that theory away say it's
bad right fine-tune bad bad go away um
this was underlying for people who know
this stuff this kind of consideration
was underlying Gore uh Gore's work on
the tetrad equations which is also Perl
learned a lot from them okay there's
this history there I don't want to go
into now the problem that happen is that
this piece of methodological advice has
been wildly
oversimplified um to this idea that GE
if the if you can't signal between here
and here then you should never accept a
theory that has a causal connection
between here and here here right you're
violating this principle uh and so I've
put it down at the bottom here if
there's a causal influence of the input
on the output then you should be able to
signal right you should cause be able to
cause an obser observable change in the
statistics of the output by varying the
input the problem is so that basically
says if you've got no signaling then
that implies no causal
connection and if somebody has a theory
that has a causal connection throw it
away right you you you you haven't
empirically refuted it but it's
methodologically
bad now what we've already seen is that
when we just looked forget about go back
to the neuron diagrams you can't really
find tune a neuron diagram because it
doesn't have these weights in it to fine
tune it's all just this you know binary
response stuff and what we saw in the
case of Billy and suie is you can have
some of these diagrams where there are
causal connections but you can't use
them to Signal because of the way the
inhibitory uh nodes have been put in
right uh
and since so here since there are no
Edge Edge weights at all the word
fine-tuning can't be the right word here
I mean the picture of fine-tuning really
is you've got a radio with you know all
these knobs and you're very carefully
setting a whole bunch of knobs to get a
particular result you're not doing that
here you can't do it in a neuron Di you
don't have those
knobs um and
so in such a case where you've got two
different causal
structures nothing fine-tuned they have
the same empirical consequences there
just may be nothing to favor one over
the other and you should just admit that
you might say look one or the other
disas is right we we're just
epistemically blind to it right we can't
we can't get at which one is right
because we have no direct access to the
underlying
structure
um
so to get us now I'm going to get us to
the result here I hope so if there is
signaling right if I have a a variable
here and I can freely set it however I
like and on the basis of doing that some
the the observable statistics of
something else change then I I then I've
got a good Shannon transmitter right now
I can apply Shannon information
information Theory I can say I want to
tell you are we going to go to lunch I I
manipulate this you look at the data you
say oh you did that okay um so it's
certainly reasonable demand that if you
can signal you better have some causal
connections
there right um the problem was right and
you you regard one of
these variables is a free variable if
anybody hasn't read John Bell's paper on
free variables in local causality which
is just about this and he hits all the
right notes I recommend you read that um
I think that's a perfectly reasonable
advice right if you can manipulate if
you can send signals then yeah there
better be a causal path running from the
transmitter to the receiver
um now I I should mention here when you
say there's a causal path it's kind of
an abstract thing it doesn't mean there
has to be a particle or energy or
anything like this um standard example
is Sherlock Holmes The Case of the dog
in the night right where Sherlock Holmes
there's a signal that
goes from the happenings in the barn out
to the house where sherock Holmes is or
where the people are why because they
because the dog didn't bark so there was
no energy there was no particles but
there was a signal why because of the
counterfactual structure if the murderer
had been a stranger the dog would have
barked they would have heard it they
didn't hear it Ergo the dog didn't bark
Ergo the murderer was familiar okay
that's a perfectly good Shannon signal
even though there's not a a physical
process that takes it from here to
here now the main thing I want to say
you should not turn that good piece of
advice around into a bad piece of advice
that says if you can't signal there
can't be any causal
connections now you might right because
the although signaling does indicate at
at least a possible causal process if
you will inab inability to Signal
doesn't indicate lack of causal
connection like the example I gave you I
delay billies throw that really does
have an effect on the causal structure
it still doesn't allow you to Signal
because of the way things are set
up so it's the
gap between these the gap between
causation and
signaling is one of the things it sends
at right at the center of Bell's theorem
and Bell's inequality you might say but
if if if I can't send a signal why
should I think there's a causal
connection at all right what's my
grounds cuz that's a good empirical
grounds and what bell
proved and this is where I would give
you the proof if I had time is that
there's certain kinds of Statistics that
cannot be
recovered from any locally causal theory
that is where where if you separate two
Labs far enough Apart Nothing that's
done in this lab can have any effect on
that nothing that's done in or happens
in that lab can have any effect on this
so that's a locally causal Theory
everybody thought the world was locally
causal Einstein sure thought the world
was locally causal the thing he was
always upset about quantum mechanics was
that it wasn't local and he always
complained about telepathy and spooky
action at a
distance um what what bell figured out
is that in any locally causal Theory
there are certain restrictions on the
sorts statistical correlations between
what happens in these Labs all right so
I'll just kind of we we're what's going
to happen is we're going to create a
pair of particles or sometimes a triple
of particles here at the center that's
the preparation of the entangled State
that's red because I can control that
right I I know what particles I'm
creating I send a particle out to
Alice's lab on one side the other
particle out to Bob's lab on the other
side Alice and Bob each have a choice of
how to set their experimental apparatus
so those are red circles and those are
their free manipulable choices they can
make them however they like and David
has done a lot of work about making them
in funny ways
um both of those clearly are causally
relevant to what happens in the
experiment right and the experiment
gives rise then to some observable
output and the statistics we have are
about the statistics of the of the
correlations between Al we know Alice's
choice we know her output we know Bob's
choice we know his output we know what
we prepared that's always the same that
doesn't vary in these cases so that's
straightforward and if it was a causally
local Theory because Alice is way over
here and Bob is way over there you're
not allowed to put an arrow going from
anywhere on Alice's side to anywhere
over on Bob's side right that's what
you're just prevented from doing and
what bell showed is that if you don't
have those there are constraints on the
statistics you can see when you compare
what happens in this lab to what happens
in that
lab now what what happens is quantum
theory predicts violations of those
constraints and then what happens even
better is the actual World violates the
constraints that's what the Nobel Prize
in physics two years ago was about was
experimental verification of violations
of bells
inequality so you get a clear thing I
have to put arrows right there has to be
some arrows going one way or the other
right this shows the world isn't locally
causal so if I want a causal diagram
I've got to have these distant causation
what can I do well I can this is now
should remind you of Billy and Susie I
hope I can put it that way I can say oh
the the thing is set up so that in fact
some of what Alice does or what happens
over there has an effect on Bob or
I can run the causal thing the other way
of course there's if you do this in a
kind of symmetric way it won't surprise
you that like the bilan suie
case empirically it won't make any
difference which way the arrows go right
the statistics are going to be the same
so you can't tell from the surface
statistics you can tell there is an
arrow but you can't tell which way it
runs okay so that becomes empirically
hidden from you
now what deter which graph are you
almost done trying to okay I'm almost
done so I want to say it's got to be you
know it's got to be one of these two
graphs um what determines which graph it
is in the case of Billy and suie the
question was the timing of the Rocks
right was it this one or that one here
it's essentially the timing of these
experiments that are done
distantly um the way the obvious way to
take care of this is now and now I have
to say I'm sorry sorry Albert relativity
is wrong you put in what's called a
preferred foliation you you you put in
essentially a kind of global time
function so that you can say who went
first you can't do this in relativity so
you're giving up on relativity you're
giving up for good reasons if a if Alice
went first then it's this graph if Bob
went first it's that graph now is that
fine-tuning right now you you can easily
see you can set this up so you can't
tell from the surface statistics who
went first you can't use to send signals
um H all right I'll just so they're
detailed examples in in Pilot wave
theory you exactly understand how this
goes um I'm just going to skip over this
because obviously I'm running too late
um and and in the collapse theories it
goes a different way but I can't back
that up so let me just say in in both of
these cases in the pilot wave theory and
the collapse theories you have no
signaling theorems Bell started these he
not only only proved this he proved
what's sometimes called the Bell
Telephone theorem that says even though
there has to be this connection you
can't use it to signal and that just
follows from certain con you know
understanding of the Dynamics um and I'm
just going through why you get also no
signaling and collapse all I want to say
at the end of this is that if you look
at any of these theories they are not in
any intuitive sense fine-tuned there's
no little parameters that have been set
there's no careful adjusting of any
knobs it's just what determines what
cause what is the actual order in time
and you know relative to this foliation
the actual order in time that's a fact
it's a physical fact we may not be able
to get our hands on it okay um I would
even say that in these cases it's you
know in a way Billy and suie are
slightly fine- tuned because they have
to throw their rocks pretty well
coordinated but because this just a
matters on who goes first it doesn't
matter there's no fine-tuning like that
you got these two events one's earlier
than the other so that's
um just saying that that piece of
methodological advice which is drawn out
of the linear causal graph tradition and
then thrown over inconsiderately I would
say over to this example and people have
used it to say oh pilot wave theory
that's no good why not it's fine-tuned
what do you mean it's fine-tuned oh go
read the uh linear causal graph
literature that's all that's happening
here it's bad it's really harming it's
harming reasonable discussion of these
cases so um I thought since I was with
people who do this stuff I would make a
plea to stop doing that okay I think
that's the end right yeah so in some
good so the methodological rule to avoid
or even forbid fine-tune causal models
where the Criterion of fine-tuning is no
signaling is completely inappropriate in
the context of these tests if the the
inequality is violated that alone the
bell's inequality that alone implies
some non-local causation no Theory
that's Bell local can make these
predictions it doesn't mean you can tell
empirically which direction the
causation goes but the inability to do
that does not imply fine-tuning in any
substantial sense of the term so that's
that than
[Applause]
[Music]
you time for one quick question
no uh yeah thanks for your talk um yes
so I totally agree with what you've said
about
fine-tuning uh and I just want to get
clear on so I mean I you someone might
see this talk and think the lesson is
that you shouldn't use caal models to
think about these scenarios while at
least what I yeah what I would suggest
is just you should actually know what
you're talking about because as you
pointed out yeah faithfulness does not
equal fine tuning so
right okay let's uh thank all the
speakers from this morning and head out
to lunch upstairs